if you want to hear three theories about
the setup for a sequel then stick around
to the end of this video
Michael Myers Jason Freddy Pennywise
Leatherface and many others have just
welcomed a new member into their
exclusive club of horror icon remakes
and that member is Chucky today I'm
things you missed I'll be covering
everything you might have missed in the
2019 child's play the new film is very
different from the original but it's
absolutely loaded with nods and
parallels to the original child's play
series many of which I think you'll be
surprised to learn the movie begins with
this introduction video to this company
Caslon who are very similar to play pals
toys from the original series and that
they produce the doll and all sorts of
accessories in fact we see the inside of
the factory where the Buddy dolls are
produced and it's very similar visually
to the factory that Chucky chases Kyle
and Andy through in child's play - it is
here that we discovered the origin of
Chuckies evil this time it's not a
serial killer transferring as evil soul
into the body but rather a factory
worker programming his evil intentions
into the source code of this toy the
worker later throws himself off the
building and lands on a car for the
first death of the movie and Maggie
lands on a car for the first death in
the original child's fly when Andy's mom
comes home from work the IT guys
installing cameras and hauls made by
Kasim so it seems like they control
almost all of the technology in this
world but I'll come back to that later
in this video
in both this and the original Andy's mom
gets the doll second hand in the
original it's a street peddler and now
it's a returned item to the store that
she works at the name of the doll has
been changed from good guys to buddy but
don't worry this isn't a betrayal of the
original it's actually a reference to
the real world doll that the original is
based on that my buddy don't legend says
that 80's kids still have the jingles
stuck in their heads and so will you
after I roll
the name change also just works well
with modern text strange gravitation
towards the lowercase eyes I guess it's
supposed to stand for Internet but after
being overused in every tech product I
think we can agree that it stands for
insufferable Andy's mom tells him to go
make friends with some of the kids
standing outside but he says he doesn't
want to they could be serial killers a
little nod to the fact that in the
original the good guy doll is possessed
by a serial killer also there's a
possible connection in that Andy likes
to draw these strange buddy-cop pairings
in his notebook could be a reference to
the two cops that helps take down Chucky
in the 1988 film there listen one of
them helps in this version the kids are
given the opportunity to give a custom
name to their toy and he names his han
solo big missed opportunity to not go
with Luke Skywalker instead seeing is
how Chucky is voiced by the man who
plays Luke Skywalker there's also a song
known as the buddy song that goes you
are my buddy until the end
the original Chucky doesn't sing but it
does have a phrase that goes were
friends to the end okay so the next part
is what I find a most interesting
because this remake has its own plots
that isn't similar to the original but
the overarching idea is the same but in
a modern setting what I'm talking about
is the fact that Chucky's voodoo
possession of the doll in the 1988 movie
causes him to slowly become human but in
the 2019 remake he's just an AI with
safety restrictions removed but he
learns how to behave by watching and
imitating humans so in a sense he is
becoming human throughout the movie
because he's learning to behave like a
human
unfortunately the humans that he's
taking his cues from are irresponsible
preteens who teach him to do bad stuff
for laughs so Chucky begins to see this
as acceptable behavior they also show
him the Texas Chainsaw Massacre too
which causes Chucky to remove one of his
victims faces and is probably influenced
by other horror movies judging from the
posters on this kid's wall like killer
clowns from outer space and poltergeist
3 both of which came out in 1988 - the
same year as the original child's play
one aspect of the new story is that Andy
has been given Chucky as an early
birthday present because his mom knows
that the move has been hard on him
there's also a point later where he
gives the gift to his neighbor and mrs.
Norris and tells her that they can open
gifts together on his birthday so
there's a looser connection here to Andy
from the original who receives the good
guy dolls
last-minute birthday gift now this next
one I don't know if I would count it as
a thing you missed maybe more of a
disturbing thing that I thought of after
the fact I'm just not gonna start a
whole web series called disturbing
things I thought about after the fact
but Chuckie starts his killing by taking
out Andy's cats and that night Chuckie
stands in his room and plays back cat
noises these were probably the sounds of
the cat's final moments pretty messed up
soundtrack to fall asleep to I think
I'll stick with lo fight chill hot beats
to study slash relax slash sleep for my
bedtime music choices
Chucky's next victim is Karen's
boyfriend Shane because for some reason
all guys who date a single mother and
horror movies turned out to be evil like
seriously tried to name one exception to
this role he's taking down Christmas
lights when Chucky finds him which tells
us that this movie still takes place in
January like the original despite the
fact that it seems to be in a warm
weather climate as opposed to Chicago
taking down the lights was a neat way to
show this without drawing too much
attention to an otherwise unnecessary
detail Chucky attacks him in a very
similar way to how Aunt Maggie is
attacked with Chucky rushing around in
the dark before knocking his victim down
from a high up plays he tears Shane's
face off and his hair lands on a garden
gnome which instantly made me think of
this keemstar video from 2016 where he
wears an emo wig and it pretends to be
leafyishere I want to kill myself also
in the news when Andy and his friends
realized that Chucky has gone too far
they take steps to deactivate it and
they do so by removing what I'm assuming
is supposed to be the battery which is
located in the center of his chest just
like the heart that they have to shoot
to kill Chucky in the original
[Music]
after doing this they toss him down the
garbage chute thinking that that'll be
it
but like child's play one two in play
Chucky always finds a way to come back
whenever you think that he's done for
and when he does he kills the pervy IT
guy that put him back together I guess
in addition to watching Texas Chain Saw
movies with Chucky they must have also
been watching some song Chucky gets back
into Andy's life by mailing himself to
one of the other kids in Andy's building
which brings up the exact same question
I had in my video on child's play 3
which is how do you wrap a package if
you're inside of it this brings us to
another interesting parallel to the
original which is that Andy is the only
one to realize that this is the same
Chucky as the one that he had and as a
result everybody thinks that Andy is
crazy the old Andy was put into a
hospital but this one just goes all
anthony rizzo on the TV could have just
unplugged it all you had to do there's
also a scene where mrs. Norris goes in a
caslen car which is like Kathleen's
version of uber and Chucky takes control
of it and crashes it remember mrs.
Norris is the mother of detective Mike
Norris and in the original detective
Norris also gets his car crash as a
result of Chucky and the part that
follows where Chucky attacks from 360
degrees around the car is very similar
in both movies the climax takes place in
the store that Andy's mom works at where
they're having the launch of the
brand-new buddy - which includes
different forms such as the Buddy bear
and obvious five nights at Freddy's
reference and the Leprechaun outfit I
guess possibly a leprechaun reference
with the idea of there being a multiple
buddy dolls being taken over by Chucky
itself is a reference to the previous
movie in the franchise cult of Chucky
where Charles Lee ray manages to get his
soul into multiple bodies I've heard
that this is an idea that they wanted to
use for a long time but didn't but if
you think about it it actually makes
sense here because Chucky is stated to
have the ability to control all Caslon
products also the RC police car that
shouts out the Robocop line could also
be a nod towards child's play three
where one of the toys that Chucky uses
to attack the playpal CEO mr. Sullivan
is this toy car those of you who watched
my video on the original child's playing
I wonder how many times I said the word
original during this video but those of
you who saw it remember my idea to make
a whole movie off the creepy mascot from
the good guy unveiling commercial well
in the new one they use a creepy mascot
during the unveiling of the actual
product in stores and while it wasn't a
whole movie I was glad to see the mascot
being used for something
it's no secret that one of the most
beloved scenes in the childsplay
franchise is the final Factory seen from
child's play to so to replicate some of
that magic the reboot throws Andy into a
final confrontation with Chucky in the
warehouse at the back of the store
something that is alluded to earlier on
when Andy's mom blackmails our co-worker
west by threatening to tell his wife
what went on between him and a woman
named Susan in the warehouse
Chucky kidnaps Andy's mom and tries to
hang her which is how he killed the
factory supervisor in child's play too
but Andy makes it just in time to save
her but as we know and have established
many times
Chucky always finds a way to come back
and this time it's detective Norris with
the heroic one-liner where he says this
is the act very similar to the og Andy's
life
except this time it really is the end
well maybe not the company caslen issues
a statement where they take no
responsibility for the incident which
parallels there PR response to their
stockholders and child's play - and an
evil buddy doll ends up on the store
shelves once more so the question about
this ending is how did Chucky survive we
saw him get shot in the chest and then
his head was pulled off there are a few
possibilities if they're trying to set
up a sequel along the lines of child's
play - it's possible that the company
reconstructed shopping to appease their
stockholders but I already covered why
that's a terrible idea under the video
on the second one so another possibility
is that this simply wasn't the only one
the disgruntled Vietnamese worker could
have made several rogue dolls for all we
know but my favourite theory is that
because this iteration of Chucky is
connected to the cloud and can interact
with other buddy dolls it could have
sent it to AI and everything that it
learned to other dolls meaning that Andy
or some unlucky kid could be up against
a whole army of Chuckies in the sequel
let me know which theory you would get
behind in the comments and I've gotten a
lot of requests to cover Bride of Chucky
seed curse and cult here on things you
missed so with a sequel probably going
to happen now I'll definitely have to do
those in the future so make sure you are
subscribed to see Izzy's world I post
new Horrors every week just wring the
death belt for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive